my name is Steve Coster I enjoy taking
whatever I have and making it work if I
was stranded on the desert island and
given a spoon to survive with I would
have a three-story home built in the
matter of six months this is a 1986
truck it's also where you'll Harvest
your steel from in this first round of
competition we've already picked the
blade for you guys to make the fully
functional friction folder
the friction folder is a blade where
whether the blade is opened or closed
friction maintains that Blade's position
good luck blade Smith sure three hour
Starts Now I know the leaf springs are
going to be the main source of material
I've never made a friction folder before
[Music]
I haven't even attempted it
but I have read about them and I've seen
demonstrations on making them so I have
a pretty good idea what it's going to
take
I decided to forge out a little pad on
the end of the Tang the concept is to
hollow out a little pocket where that
tab would fit in the pocket come down
and stop the Tang from going any farther
into the handle
I'm telling you I'm really impressed
with the work that Steve's doing
I'm really trying to draw down as much
material on the bevels to get the edge
of the blade straight Steve looks like
he's going to go for a quench
I don't have any warps I'm pretty happy
with things the way they turned out
two one Blaze fish shut down your
machines drop your tools this first
round of friction folder competition is
over all right Steve you may present
your blade
this is the kind of work that we really
appreciate from around one what I see
here service to design not to fit the
parameters but overall function putting
that there one of the biggest issues
we've had from previous competitions is
that this piece becomes a shank that
seems to puncture everybody that holds
on to it we thought about that and I
truly appreciate it good job thank you
very much
blade Smith's congratulations you've
made it into the second round of this
competition and now that your blades
have been tempered it's time to turn
them into fully functional friction
folders by attaching handles to them
good luck Blake Smith sure three hour
Starts Now I really need to concentrate
on the handle I'm a little can
[Music]
I drill three different holes in
different spaces in my handle material
and I can swing the blade and see where
it closes and where it opens I've got
everything together and then I realized
that I fully quenched my blade which
means I have a fully hardened blade
and a fully hardened blade can be
brittle and I really don't want my blade
to be brittle for the bumper chop I want
it to have a soft back
so I blew back my spine what Steve's
doing is he's really building for the
test that blue backing was really a
smart idea
the friction part of it works opening
and closing pretty good uh just the
handle is just too fast so I really need
to
beat it down a little bit
five four three two one placement shut
down your machines drop your tools this
second round of competition is over
welcome to the strength test
you can test the strength and durability
of your friction folders I'll be
batoning them into this car bumper
remember this test is all about what
that bumper does to your friction
folders and not the other way around
what do you thinking Steve
I think and I'm about ready to find out
I'm thinking you are
well Steve your Edge took some roll from
the bumper mostly at the point here
your handle is comfortable I like the
swell up here near the front it's it's
gives me my hand a place to live it all
held up it's all one piece well done
thank you very much this is
sharpness test the seat belt straps
slice
now unlike the strength test this is all
about what the edge of your weapon will
do to these seat belt straps all right
Steve it's your turn you ready
yeah I think so
there you go
you can't do this enough to where I can
wrap my hand around so I get a good grip
with that grip it allows easier to index
and slash with it your Edge cut easily
through all the seat belt straps it is
sharp and it will cut thank you good job
John Steve congratulations you've made
it into the final round of this
competition now we're seeing you back to
your home for just to recreate an iconic
weapon from history that weapon is
the Javanese Chris ah
pretty excited to be doing the Javanese
Chris the Chris normally has a pretty
coarse pattern to it okay here we go so
I'm gonna do a pattern welded blade
right now I'm starting to forge the
Billet into a nice taper come on
I need to spread this out a little more
and then I'll start forge the curves
into it I ended up just forging them
with a hammer over the horn on the Anvil
and I really don't want to grind it to
the blade yeah I think forging it by
hand is the way to go
the whole purpose of forging is to try
to forge as close to shape as you can it
saves time later on when I go to the
grinder but I have to be careful to not
bend it too much
Blade's been tempering overnight
oh baby look at that that's exactly what
I was looking for now I just got to
start on the handle
I'm choosing KOA because I'm kind of
obsessed with it it's just unbelievable
the way it looks turns my crank so to
speak
before I do a final assembly I'm going
to keep sanding until I get it looking
to where I want then all I have to do is
a little bit of epoxy pin it boom it's
done that's what it's going to look like
the blade is finished the handle's on
but the Java Chris is very symbolic it
has little meanings hidden all over it
and what I need to do is set this in
there with the hole so I'm going to add
six Garnet Stones around that collar and
they symbolize Health yeah I think it's
happening and the handle is a striped
hardwood and that is a symbol of a
Javanese tiger I like
I already have the elephant trunk near
the guard and that provides strength for
the blade I hope it'll win Steve welcome
back to the forage tell us about your
blade
it's a all forged 25 layers the 1084 15
and 20. I use koa wood on the handle to
symbolize the Javanese tiger I think it
turned out pretty good your weapons will
now be put through a series of three
tests a kill test a sharpness test and a
strength test up first the kill test
Doug
all right blade Smith this
it will damage your weapon will do I
will take your crisis and deliver
slashes and thrusts on this big carcass
all right Steve it's your turn you ready
yep let's do this
oh
dude that's impressive all right Steve
let's talk about your Chris here the
balance of this blade is really good
it's done in such a way to where I can
really get speed in cutting and because
your angles of the edge over here is
almost like an acute Edge it allows to
cut deeply into this big carcass it's
light it's fast and it's sharp and it
will kill thank you very much welcome to
the strength test
to test the strength and durability as
well as the overall construction of your
Javanese crisp I'm going to be stabbing
them in and out of these oil drums
remember this test is all about what
these drums do to your swords and not
what your swords do to these drums Steve
you're up next you ready yep all right
[Music]
well Steve I love the shape and the
design of your Chris it's very classic I
don't see any damage even though it's
stabbed quite deeply into the drum is
still razor sharp
well done thank you
it's time for the sharpest test
they'll be attacking these bags with
stabs and slashes and unlike the
strength test this is all about what
your blades do to those targets Steve
you're up you ready yeah
foreign
all right Steve design wise your blade I
really like it your handle I like that I
know that's not going anywhere it's easy
to index as far as the cuts go
I think they speak for themselves
they're all clean straight through
really good job Steve thank you very
much appreciate it
congratulations you are the new forged
and fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
that one yeah
I don't know what to say I'm glad it
happened you know the cutting just tells
the story John did really good job I
think my blade just cut a little better
than his my name's Steve Coster and I am
the winner of forged and fires
foreign